from speaking to some of the miners here
in Marikana they felt that the
politicians had a very large role to
play in how their tragedy unfolded and
they're very angry because we do know
that the deputy president has the
Ramaphosa he wrote an email to Lonmin
management asking them to take
concomitant action regarding the
distracting miners and that added to the
climate of fear throughout that period
and - certainly feels that the
politicians are getting away scot-free
and now the police hierarchy in a sense
is going to be taking the blame for it
who made the order for the man is to be
shut down the report hasn't clarified
that issue but it was very critical in
terms of the police's actions
specifically on the day of the massacre
because we do know that the police were
entirely unprepared or the volume of -
we're going to be on the copy and the
strategy that they use of circling them
barbed wire and then leaving a small gap
for the miners - to pass through as they
leave their weapons on the ground that
strategy failed it was abysmal innocent
because they circling of the miners
actually caused the tragedy and as we
know so many people died on that day in
terms of the miners themselves they were
very unhappy and what the prison had to
say about their own because the miners
feel that they were the victims they
feel that they were the ones who were
being targeted by the police they feel
that the government and the police in
particular had no role to play in a
simple wait strike between the miners
and London so for the government to now
actually come and blame the money for
the involvement in a wage strike with
the employer is something that they can
tolerate at this prison and the people
that I spoke to were very angry at the
prisons and they felt that they were
misrepresented in terms of what he had
to say about it if you were to look at
Maracana now compared to three years ago
very little has changed there's still a
very large sprawling and squatter
settlement that many of the miners are
live in there have been some
improvements in terms of the hostels and
in some of the dwellings that the man is
due live in but the vast majority of
them do not own houses
and the situation is still really the
same which has caused a lot of
dissatisfaction amongst the miners
because following this tragedy and
wanted hope that there would have been a
large-scale intervention by London and
by government to ensure that the lives
of these miners improves and to
compensate them for the tragedy that
they faced on that on that fateful day
but the situation hasn't improved these
guys are migrant laborers that come from
far-flung areas of South Africa and they
come here to try and make a bit of
living for themselves and see their
families back home but actually
achieving that there's very little
financial reward for them it's still a
daily struggle for the amount of
constant basis